una fuerza a la sombra que no deja
rastro el grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner
que será designado como organización
criminal transnacional por Estados
Unidos ha actuado como brazo armado del
kremlin en distintos conflictos en todo
el mundo Ucrania es apenas un nuevo
capítulo de esta historia pero Cómo
opera esta organización ha tenido
participación en Siria Libia República
centroafricana Sudán y Mali entre otros
en Ucrania actuó por primera vez en
ocasión de la anexión de crimea en 2014
fundada por un cercano Aliado de Putin y
Jenny Wagner no tiene registro legal en
ninguna parte del mundo ese vacío
jurídico le da Carta blanca para actuar
sin comprometer el kremlin a cambio se
financia con el saqueo de recursos
naturales en los países donde opera y
tráfico de bienes difíciles de rastrear
ese es el problema que es una
organización que oficialmente
en vista de que la ley rusa prohíbe los
grupos vamos a decirlo privado militares
o mercenarios Pues es lo que es
realmente Así que cuando ellos pues han
estado combatiendo en Siria República
centroafricana Mali por ejemplo o en el
don paz en 2014 y tras la invasión del
dos en Ucrania Pues claro oficialmente
es hay un algo nebuloso inesperadamente
se cree que Wagner ha tenido rosas con
las autoridades militares rusas durante
la operación en Ucrania nuestra
información indica que el ministro tiene
reservas sobre los métodos de
reclutamiento de Wagner según Estados
Unidos 80% de los hombres de Wagner
destacados en Ucrania son convictos
reclutados en las cárceles de Rusia
pregoche no confirma cifras pero sí la
práctica les dije que necesitaba sus
talentos criminales para matar al
enemigo en la guerra estos talentos ya
no son necesarios recuerden bien que no
necesitan volver a prisión es la fórmula
perfecta para librar a Rusia de
acusaciones por crímenes de guerra al
mismo tiempo que frena el recuento
formal de bajas en sus filas